in the winter he said that that's when
it started i'm like okay
so
when we're here on spring break why
can't you tell me then yes because i
couldn't tell you because i didn't want
to and i'm like okay but why he goes
just cuz and i'm like
okay and i literally that was oh that
was on the second time i went crazy
again like out of our drinking i was
like throwing punches i was screaming
and crying like in the alleyway
you were punching him you thank you like
in the chest though not the face
it doesn't make it
no no it doesn't well then it's fine
of course
but but wait you had you really had no
leg to stand
you were punching him
not full on i think i was just like
that answer your crazy question yes
hundred percent
so one what i'm trying to say is
forever
but what i'm trying to say most people
can imagine if a man came on a podcast
and said yeah i was punching this girl
and yeah i was going
yeah yeah yeah it's a double standard
it's crazy
yeah it's a double standard
oh my god i'll be canceled tomorrow i'll
be cancelled
were you done with him after that
oh man it's not really oh dang i see
both loves kind of cheated on you then
yeah have you cheated
have you cheated um not on
never actually not on never what was
what was that answer
okay
no woman i've ever spoken to has ever
cheated apparently yeah not anyone that
i've ever taken seriously and i knew
that they were taking me seriously as
well so like if i was like you know
hooking up with you like every so often
like obviously
yeah but like like with
but when he's asking like have you ever
cheated on a man or your partner so i
don't have to fight like anything yeah
yeah um has it been for someone you've
been in an active relationship with or
you've had that exclusivity conversation
like that agreement that's when you're
saying cheating like have you ever
cheated on anyone no never there was
never agreement where we were like oh
yeah so you've never never okay you
never cheated never sorry that's
probably have you ever cheated no no
has anyone here ever cheated no
no
yeah of course no woman's ever cheated
it's never been done i feel like
whenever you commit that that's your
commitment you made like no i'm just
nothing
i'm just saying like no woman not
exactly if you don't come out of that no
the thing is when i speak the thing is
when i speak right i speak to guys and
they say yeah there was something that
happened blah blah blah but for some
reason
women have a hard time admitting that
they've cheated